A channel grant is the single most
important message on a trunked system: the
moment it is broadcast, a call is
starting, and the message says exactly
where.
Everything trunking promises — many
groups, few channels — comes down to this
one transaction.
A user keys up.
Their radio sends a call request on the
control channel.
The site controller picks a free voice
channel from the pool, packs an answer
into a short signalling block, and
broadcasts it: talkgroup 101, go to
channel 3.
Every radio affiliated to talkgroup 101
hears that grant and retunes together, in
a fraction of a second.
So does every monitor following the
system.
One message, and an entire group — plus
everyone listening in — moves to the same
place at the same instant.
Look inside the message and there are
three essentials.
First, the target: a talkgroup for a group
call, or a source-and-destination pair for
a private call.
Second, the channel — usually not a raw
frequency, but a channel number the radio
maps to a frequency through the system's
channel plan.
And third, on TDMA systems, a timeslot,
because two calls can share one frequency
in time.
A grant is broadcast once — but a radio
might miss it.
It was out of range, powered off, or busy
on another channel.
So while the call runs, the control
channel repeats a grant update announcing
the call in progress.
A late arrival reads the update and joins
mid-call.
That is late entry, and it is why trunked
systems feel seamless even as radios come
and go.
The flavors mirror the traffic: group
voice grants for the everyday case,
unit-to-unit grants for private calls
between two radio IDs, grant updates for
late entry, and data grants that assign a
channel for a short packet transfer
instead of voice.
One more wrinkle: a grant is a promise of
a free channel, and sometimes there isn't
one.
During a busy incident the controller may
queue the request instead, and the grant
arrives seconds later when a channel frees
up.
Grade of service, made audible.
GopherTrunk's trunk-following engine is,
at heart, a grant reader.
Every grant on the control channel is
parsed in real time; the channel number
runs through the decoded channel plan to
become a frequency; and a receiver is
tasked at that frequency — and that
timeslot — before the first syllable of
audio arrives.
Repeat for every grant, and one wideband
capture reconstructs the whole system's
traffic.
So: a channel grant is the control-channel
message that assigns a call to a voice
channel.
It names the target, the channel, and on
TDMA the slot — and its updates repeat
mid-call so latecomers can join.
Full write-up linked below.